SUNIT UNAR: Hi, everybody.
My name is Sunit.
I'm looking after the
AdMob business development
here in EMEA.
And today, I have some pretty
interesting agenda for you,
because today,
I'm going to share
with you three new product
launches in Google AdMob,
plus a new Business
Development kit that we just
released for the
developer communities.
So to start with,
first, I would like
to share with you
this wheel again
that Thomas shared
with you in the morning
sessions-- and the
idea of this wheel
and to share it with
you guys, because we
have a bunch of
different Google products
which is available for
the developer communities.
To give you an
idea about what you
can use at different stages
of your development cycle--
you build your
game, and then you
work for growing your audience.
And then when you [INAUDIBLE]
your audience-- that
is that the third part
is engaging your players.
And then when you
engage your players,
you're going to think about how
to monetize your application
or games.
That's why we have different
products in Google, which
is available for you guys--
Google AdMob publicly
for publishers and where
Google Wallet stands for.
So today, the focus will
be more on Google AdMob.
But as most of you
predicted, it's
much more than a
mobile ad network.
And I would like to tell you a
little bit about the history--
how Google AdMob evolved
after we acquired it in 2013.
So when we first
acquired Google AdMob,
we realized that there has been
a lot to do with the product.
We need to develop it further
to make it much more profitable
for the developer communities
and for the gamers.
So we let our strong
advertiser base
to meet with all the
AdMob publishers which
is all available in the AdMob.
And then we built new
programs and new features
in the product, such as
advanced mediation features
and such as new ad formats.
And we tried to make this
product much more quality
for all the developer
communities.
And then when it
comes to 2014, we
are now much more
confident to say
that we are in a strong position
where we can make this product
to work cross-functional for
all the developers out there.
When I say a cross-functional,
I mean not only advertising,
but also I mean in a
purchase, for example.
Today, one of our
new launches is
going to be about
this topic, and I'm
going to tell you
further how we made
Google AdMob a great
monetization tool for you guys
to boost your in-app
purchase revenue,
but not only your ad revenue.
Also, the second
announcement of today
is going to be the integration
of Google Analytics
together with
Google AdMob and how
it helps you to understand
your audience better
and to segment your
users accordingly
and to take necessary actions.
When we look at monetization,
monetization is a huge topic.
It's a conundrum, actually.
And when we look at it,
we need to understand
what are the different ways
that is available in the market
today.
And as you know, freemium is
one of the dominating ways
to monetize your application--
together with in-app purchases.
But we also have paid downloads.
It's still standing there
for just another option.
And also, we have
advertising solutions.
I'm sure most of
mobile ad networks
out there are communicating
to you everyday
by sending email or calling you
to be able to work with you.
And when we have a look at
these different options,
we need to understand what's
the trend for the future.
We need to understand
where the industry's going.
So when we have a look
at the premium downloads
and the freemium downloads
in the market today,
we have seen a drastic increase
in the freemium downloads.
And when we forecast the future
and the growth of the freemium
downloads, it's going to
increase much more and more--
up to 95% with growth rate.
So we can see clearly see
that in-app purchase is
one of the dominant monetization
options for you guys,
for the developer communities.
And we need to understand
how in-app spending is
in [INAUDIBLE] with our
future business model
and with our future
business plans.
So we need to see which
markets are strongest
for us to increase-- to boost
our net-purchase revenue
whereas which
markets we can focus
on some other monetization
models-- such as advertising
or such as carrier
billing, for example.
So when we have a look at
the major markets today,
globally, we can see that
Germany and UK is dominating
in terms of in-app purchase
ratio for all the users
whereas US and France is coming
a little bit from behind.
So when I say
today, we are going
to talk about how we turned
AdMob into a monetization
solution for you-- not
only for ads, but also
for in-app purchase-- we
also need to understand how
our users are
interacting with us
and what percentage of our
users are doing in-app purchases
from our games.
So when we have a look
at the general ratio
of our in-app purchase
users-- yesterday,
I was talking to one
of the developers
here from social
games, and my friend
was just telling me that
only 3.2% of their users
are doing in-app purchase
within their games.
So this is a question that
we need to all think about.
What's happening to
the rest of the 97%?
I appreciate all the cool
stuff, all the great games
that you are building--
they're great games.
They're just growing
the ecosystem
just as we would like to do.
But at the same time,
we need to think about
and we need to ask this
question ourselves.
Are we really taking and
grasping all the money
on the table which is out there
and which is ready for us?
So it's not about showing
ads to every unique user
that you have, but it's about
maximizing our yield management
and maximizing it in a way that
we combine our in-app purchase
revenue with the
advertising revenue.
So let's have a look at what
are the current technology
in Google AdMob that we allow
our developers to use today.
So when we have a look at the
typical life-cycle of a game
developer in the
ad-monetization cycle,
we see three
different categories.
First, a game developers starts
to monetize with an ad network.
And then secondly,
the developer starts
to think about mediating
in between different ad
networks-- third party
sales or companies.
And then the last--
maturity cycle
is when you think about
integrating direct sales
into our games and
integrating your direct sales
activities together
with third party sales
companies and other
ad networks out there.
So I will first start
to share with you what
AdMob is able to provide
in the first cycle,
and then we are
going to continue
with the second
and then the last.
So if you ever search for
Google AdMob in the internet,
in the forums, or even
in the social media,
you're going to
see that fill-rate
is one of the trending topics
for Google AdMob today.
It is because we have
such a strong advertiser
base in the [? AdVerse ?]
product inventory,
and our advertisers, all
these premium advertisers,
are all out there--
which is more than one
million mobile bidders
today-- is out there to bid
for your mobile applications,
to show their ads
within your games or
within your applications.
So this is why we have
such a strong position
today in the market,
where we have up to 99%
fill-rate in the market.
And secondly, if you ever
search for Google AdMob again,
and the second trending
topic that you're
going to see-- especially after
the Flappy Birds example--
that people,
developers out there
are talking about the high
eCPMs of Google AdMob.
And they look happy.
They are happy.
We know they're happy,
because back in two years
when we searched
for Google AdMob--
I remember two years ago, I
was reading a developer forum.
And developers were
all complaining
about how eCPMs were
low in Google AdMob.
And we got our lesson.
We worked on it, and we tried
to make our product first,
much more profitable
for developers.
And secondly, much more
quality for the developers.
So what happened-- and our eCPMs
grew by 300% in the last year--
is first of all, we launched new
products like CPM Floor Launch.
And now secondly, we launched
the new product user interface
and the new AdMob
front-end user interface.
And it came up with new product
features such as Ad Network
Optimization.
And then by mid 2013, we rolled
all interstitial ad formats
globally to all the developers.
And lastly, we have seen
some seasonality factors
during the Christmas time.
So let's have a look at what
are all the different ad
formats available to make
this profit available for you,
to make this 300% eCPM
growth available for you.
First of all, we
have Smart Banners.
So when the first mobile ad
networks started to evolve,
the very first ad format,
which has been used
was the classical banners.
But the problem with
the classical banners
was they were not
able to orient and get
with an orientation
of your device.
So the image of a
classical banner
was not optimized for
all the screen sizes.
And that's where we launched
Smart Banners in Google AdMob
in 2012.
And smart banners
were able to orient
with an orientation
of your screen,
and we were able to deliver
the ads accordingly.
So this is a good example of a
Smart Banner in the Hill Climb
Racing H from Fingersoft.
And the second type of ad
formats we have available today
is full screen
interstitial ad formats.
It was available until mid 2013
only to those beta testers.
But starting from mid 2013,
we rolled out these ad formats
to all global
developer communities.
And today, it's available for
all the developers out there.
And the third
different ad format
is video ad format, which is
the TrueView experience that you
all have experienced in YouTube.
We brought the
TrueView experience
into mobile applications, and we
launched the TrueView ad format
into mobile applications.
And just a piece of
note on this-- this
is the first TrueView ad
format in a mobile application
ecosystem.
And the reason why we would
like to see TrueView ad
formats into mobile applications
is because users are highly
engaging with this
type of ad formats.
And by looking at their consent,
by looking at their will,
we need to clearly
understand which
users would like to see
this type of ad formats
whereas which users are
just skipping the ads
and not showing it.
So this is a good example of
how video ad experience looks
like in your application.
And in the first
screen, you're going
to see how the
gameplay looks like.
And whenever the user
pauses the game or times
out or during the
level intersection,
we will give the
impression to the TrueView
and the user either skips
the ad or just watches it.
So what's new today is
in-app purchase ad formats.
And I just shared with you that
one of the big announcements
of today is we are announcing
the in-app purchase ad
formats for the first time
for European app developers.
And it was priorly announce
in [? GDSS ?] San Francisco
last week.
So what's coming new
with in-app purchase
ad format is-- the
idea is we know
that you want to increase your
in-app purchase revenue as
well as you want to
increase your ad revenue.
So how you can increase your
in-app purchase revenue?
Just have a look at the
example that I shared with you
from the social point.
So social point is saying
only 3% of their users
are doing in-app purchase.
So the ideal solution is to
increase this 3% up to 5%,
up to 6%, or even 10%.
And how do we do it?
So the idea here
is first of all,
we define our in-app
product catalog.
We define what different
types of products we're
going to offer to our users.
And then after we
define our product,
we are going to create
a user list for us.
We are going to create
a targeting list.
To show these ads,
these products
to the different users, we
need to target those users.
Let's think we have
100,000 users who
are playing our
games, and we want
to find those users in
between this 100,000 who
played our game in the last 24
hours, who reached to level 10,
and who got stuck there.
So now, we have the risk
of losing those users
if they don't keep
playing and if they
don't reach the level 10.
And we can target those users,
and we can show our in-app ad
formats to those users by
looking at their 24 hours
traffic, by looking
at their session,
and by looking at different
dimensions, such as country,
demography, and age,
and language here.
So the idea here is not only
to show in-app purchase ads
to your users, but also
to segment your users
in a best way.
When I say "segmenting
your users,"
it's not only in-app purchase
versus non-in-app purchase.
It's also to understand
your users segmentation
with the AdMob filterings
available for in-app purchase
ad formats.
So the second
announcement of today
is we have been working on
integrating Google Analytics
into AdMob and to allow this
product to the developer
communities as a
unified product which
should be used in
conjunction together.
And the idea is we need to
understand our users in order
to maximize our monetization
value from them.
And when I say "we
need to maximize
the value from each users,"
I would mean not only
trying to understand if they're
purchasing any digital goods
from our application,
but also I would
like to say we need to
understand at which session
our users are withdrawing
to play our games
or at which session are
the users more integrating
with our games.
So the ideal solution is to
have much more engaged users
at the end by having
all the analytics
data in the same interface.
This is in the
beta program still.
And when you start using the
analytics integration together
with Google AdMob--
this is the front-end--
you will see you will
have another tab here
which is saying Analyze.
And from the
front-end, you will be
able to see different dimensions
of your users such as behavior,
such as acquisition, such
as the number of users,
such as the session, and
such as the real time
value of our users also, as
well as the device breakdown.
So what can Google Analytics
integration bring to us?
What's the additional
value of it?
First of all, it's a
cross-platform product
and it allows us to run
our monetization promotion
and analyze campaigns at one
front-end user interface.
So it's a single
product which can
help us to analyze our users, to
promote our mobile applications
or games, or to monetize
our games and applications.
And as you can see, it's a
very clear and simplified user
interface.
So you integrated analytics.
You started monetizing
your applications.
You started showing ads
from different advertisers
of Google.
And the question,
is how am I going
to control my mobile
application or my game?
And how am I going
to see which ads
am I showing up to my users?
So we also worked on
our filtering options
and we revamped the
filtering options
available to Google AdMob.
Now, we have four
different categories
how to target our users and
how to show adds to our users.
You can filter out specific
ads or specific companies
by having your URL filter level,
by having application level,
and also category/site filter
level, and text filter level.
Let's say you're
a game developer
and you're showing ads
in your application
with Google AdMob
user interface,
and you wouldn't like to show
ads from other game companies--
obviously.
So you can do a category
level by filtering out gaming
as a category.
From that moment
on, you would not
show any gaming
ads to your users.
So now, we are at the second
stage of a typical game
developer when he starts
monetizing with ads
and where we need to have a
look at what are the other ad
networks out there and what is
the solution from Google AdMob
to mediate in between
different ad networks.
So the last product launch today
is Ad Network Optimization,
and Ad Network Optimization
has been launched a month ago.
And the reason why we needed
such a tool, such a feature
in Google AdMob is because
we understand the real value
of all the ad
networks out there.
Because we know that they are
not created equally naturally.
And we need to understand what
is the value of Ad Network
Optimization here.
First of all, you will be able
to access to the real time CPM
information or other
ad networks out there.
So you can maximize
your yield management
by looking at these real time
CPM values from different ad
networks.
And secondly, you can set up
an Impression Goal Campaign
and limit the number of
impressions that you set up
for your [INAUDIBLE] campaign.
Let's say you want to
cross-promote your games,
and you want to set up a
[INAUDIBLE] campaign in Google
AdMob, and you want to limit
the number of impressions
that you give to the users
per session or per user.
So this is a feature
that will enable
you to go in this direction.
And we have another
solution which
will facilitate your mediation
stack if you ever it set up
in Google AdMob,
and it will allow
you to maximize your
value or to maximize
the value of each
impression that you
get from these
different ad networks.
Let's say you want to work
with two or three different ad
networks.
And you can create-- you
can set up a mediation stake
by saying I want to be Ad
Network X, Ad Network Y, and Ad
Network Z.
So AdMob eCPM Floor Beta feature
is providing you the ability
to set up minimum eCPMs
for each ad network,
and it will help you to maximize
the value of each ad impression
that you can get from these
three different ad networks.
So you can create your
mediation stack and do better
targeting with AdMob
eCPM Floor Beta.
And if you ever mediated between
different ad networks, what
you are going to observe,
what you're going to see
is your eCPMs is not going to
be stable, for obvious reasons.
Let's say you implemented
a mobile ad network,
and you test it
for a while and you
have seen that you're eCPMs
are fluctuating widely.
So the reality is that not all
ad network is created equally
naturally, and every ad network
has had differently eCPM values
by looking at different factors,
such as the advertiser demand,
such as the seasonality, and
such as the local ad network
factors.
Because some ad networks
are locally, much more
stronger than the other ad
networks in some local markets,
and those ad networks are going
to bring you much value it
in those markets where
they're standing strong for.
So all you need to do is
to find the optimum value
and to find the optimum
eCPM from each ad network
so you can focus on it and you
set up your mediation stake
by looking at these
optimum eCPM values.
And now, we are at the last
stage, which is maturity,
for a typical game developer
in ad-monetization life-cycle.
So in the maturity
stage, a developer
would like to understand
all possible values
that he can benefit
from in the market-- not
only all different ad
networks out there,
but also the direct
sales activities.
Let's say you have a game
and you have a strong user
base in a local market,
and those advertisers
in those local markets
are approaching
you to show their ads in your
applications or in your games.
And this is going to
be a great deal for you
because they're offering
you a much better deal
than any other ad
networks out there.
So the need here is that the
developer communities out there
needs a tool where they can
set up their direct sales
additionally with all
the other ad networks,
and they can set up their DFP
text onto their applications
and games, and they can
manage all their yield
management from that tool.
So this is where,
as Google, we're
offering DoubleClick
for publishers
as a solution to the
developer communities
where they can integrate
their direct sales
activities with all their
ad network activities.
And one of the
last announcements
today is going to be the
App Developer Business
Kit by the AdMob Marketing team.
We first announced it in JDC
San Francisco last week as well.
So if you ever visit
google.com/admob,
you will find out a really
useful page which will gave you
some ideas about the consumer
research in the key markets
and such as the best practices
of all other ad networks,
not only AdMob.
Also, it will give you some
success stories and interviews
with the successful
publishers and advertisers
of Google AdMob.
So I would strongly recommend
you to visit this page
and have a look, and
it could give you
an idea about how to
set up your business
model around your
mobile apps and games.
And AdMob, from now
on, is not going
to be only a solution for
you guys as an ad network,
but it's going to be
an ad server, an ad
network, and an analytics tool
by the integration of Google
Analytics.
So by using AdMob, you
will be able to understand
your audience with
Google Analytics.
It could give you an idea
about how to segment your users
and how to take necessary
actions upon it.
And then you can
grow your revenue.
You can grow your
in-app purchase revenue
by showing ads to the right
people at the right time.
And also, it will help you to
maximize your in-app purchase
revenue.
It will not only be an ad
network solution for you.
So you can also maximize
the value of each user
that you have today.
And this is all
from my side today.
And I will be open for another
five minutes to your questions,
if you have any.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: All right.
Do you charge for
cross-promotion?
SUNIT UNAR: Pardon me?
AUDIENCE: Do you charge
for cross-promotion?
SUNIT UNAR: No, all the
cross-promotion products
and in-app purchase ad formats
are free products for you.
And no matter how
many impressions
that you are targeting
for, it's going
to be a free service
from Google AdMob.
AUDIENCE: Wonderful, thank you.
SUNIT UNAR: One question here.
AUDIENCE: All right, I've
been seeing some problems--
not with AdMob but with
one of your competitors.
If we push several million
new users into the product,
then the mediation
layer-- has it
been able to keep
up with traffic?
So the eCPM has
fluctuated crazily-- well,
what we do apart from spread
out the new users over a longer
period of time to give the
mediation layers time to react,
build up the profiles?
SUNIT UNAR: That's a
great question, actually.
So when you set up
a mediation stack,
you can specify
more than one rule.
And this means that eCPMs are
not always the same-- globally.
So let's say you set
up a mediation state.
You want to show ads
first from Google AdMob,
second, from Ad Network X,
and third, from Ad Network Y.
And you set up these
rules, globally,
but it means that AdMob
is not able to give you
the same amount of eCPM from
all different markets out there.
We can see that AdMob is
strong in certain markets--
in those global or
strong markets such as US
or such as north Europe.
But whereas, we can see
some other ad network out
there is going to bring you
much more revenue than AdMob
could do.
So what you could do is you
could segment your mediation
stack by looking at the
different geographies where
you can get most eCPMs.
And you can create and you can
set up a different mediation
stack by focusing
on the geographies
and the strong eCPMs
from those geographies.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Any others?
OK, thank you very much, Cuneyt.
SUNIT UNAR: Thank you.